[Music]
hola hello i'm karis clavier and I love
traveling the world but today I want to
show you some of my favorite spots in my
hometown of Valencia we start our tour
in the heart of the city at the main
market Marriott center on vamos
[Music]
maybe
think that is really tasty
not gonna be the more for neg antibody
at this place sent the colors the fresh
fruit and vegetables
I like wandering round the market and I
enjoy showing visitors around
- yeah Nicholas
well there's a time now to head for the
old silk exchange another famous
landmark in Valencia
[Music]
we are very proud of this building it
was declared a UNESCO World Heritage
Site in 1996 on December the 7th my
birthday this is the most impressive
room elegant columns in Si de they say
silk and other products were traded here
from the 15th century onwards furnace a
movie important
[Music]
I also like taking visitors around the
old center of Valencia this district
with its narrow streets is called el
caramel and used to be pretty rundown
and some 20 years ago restoration began
and now a lot of young people live here
people they Cassidy was the old
buildings have interesting features like
cast iron balconies that are decorated
with tiles for the region to leave the
past behind us and head for Valencia's
most modern landmark which will really
surprise you this is the city of Arts
and Sciences it's made up of a number of
different buildings they include the
Opera House in tambien this whole
complex reflects our mentality in
Valencia we do things in a big way
[Music]
it's getting dark so time to end our
tour by the sea I hope you enjoyed it
and that your common visitors one day
here in Valencia see you then
be Sita charles peele a hill
[Music]
you